[Música]
revista de prensa con Marta Moya Marta
Buen día para usted Buenos días Ángela
bien en esta sección de hoy vamos a
hablar del emblemático semanario
estadounidense Time que cumple este
viernes tres de marzo nada más y nada
menos que 100 años de historia un siglo
consolidándose como la revista más
consumida del país con más de un millón
de suscriptores y más de 5000 números a
las espaldas Así es Ángela vamos a
hablar de esta revista icónica con el
marco rojo que todas y todos conocemos
para celebrarlo el Time ha diseñado pues
este mosaico con 144 de sus más icónicas
y relevantes portadas en un proyecto
llamado Un siglo de impacto
la ceo Jessica shibli Y el editor
general Edward fessenhall han dicho de
este número que es extraordinariamente
especial y que es un marcador de
constancia y cambio no que esté Time
después de 100 años reportándose como
revistas de referencia ya no solo en
Estados Unidos sino en todo el mundo a
lo largo de esta semana han empezado a
sacar este proyecto que está disponible
en su web donde repasan la historia del
magazine con sus artífices sus portadas
y algunas entrevistas de todos estos
Cien años de historia la revista publicó
una nota en la que dice que a lo largo
de todo el año van a hacer diferentes
eventos con personalidades políticas con
atletas activistas a lo largo de todo el
mundo y vamos a hacer hoy un repaso
breve por la historia de este semanario
empezamos destacando un pequeño clip del
director creativo
en el que dice que es para él El
concepto Time escuchemos
todos estamos inundados de millones y
millones de imágenes que nos lanzan cada
día
siempre es gratamente sorprendente ver
como una portada de Time puede abrirse
paso en ese abarrotado panorama
mediático
de Time tiene que ser Clara gráfica y a
veces provocativa
pero siempre intenta arrojar un tema de
importancia dentro de ese marco rojo
intento pensar en ella como un póster
periodístico de nuestro tiempo
[Música]
Ahora nos vamos a traer al inicio de ese
tres de marzo de 1923 hace hoy
exactamente 100 años y vamos a ver otro
fragmento de vídeos sobre cómo se fraguó
la primera portada de este semanario
escuchemos la primera portada de Time
fue el 3 de marzo de 1923 henrys y los
dos fundadores de Time andaban
febrilmente de un lado para otro
intentando averiguar Cómo sacar el
número en el último minuto pensaron
Bueno necesitamos tener una portada
recurrieron a un amigo suyo publicista
él creó esos pequeños pergaminos con
dibujos hechos a mano a los lados
estaban tratando de averiguar quién era
el sujeto de nuestra portada y fue el
presidente de la cámara Joseph Canon
la noticia de portada fue sobre el
legislador republicano conocido como el
tío show que anunciaba por aquel
entonces su jubilación una portada con
el rostro visible de este legislador con
ese marco con esos trazados a mano en
los bordes de la revista y los
fundadores de por aquel entonces
quisieron poner la cara en el centro de
la portada porque según ellos las
personas no solo hacen la noticia sino
que hacen las historias y sobre esta
premisa pues han venido trabajando
durante todo este siglo es maravilloso
ver las portadas Y cómo en la
graficación y el estilo ha cambiado con
el paso del tiempo y respecto al
imaginario actual Pues que tenemos de la
revista portada roja Así es Ángela y
vamos a hacer un breve repaso porque al
final son 100 años un poco como ha
evolucionado
esta graficación de la revista no
empezamos en la década de los 20 cuando
vemos esos pergaminos en los costados
hechos a manos con los protagonistas de
las historias siempre en en el centro en
1926 empieza esta idea de innovar con el
color que luego se materializa ya a
partir de 1927 con ese célebre marco
rojo en la década en la década de los 30
el color empieza a consolidarse en las
portadas tenemos a Gandhi por ejemplo
como personaje destacado en 1931 en el
35 vemos a la actriz Jane que también
era un icono también del erotismo en
Estados Unidos y vemos también a finales
de esa década de los 30 como esas
franjas hechas a mano empiezan a
desaparecer en los 40 la llegada de la
editora Danna tasker cambia un poco la
dinámica de las portadas porque es la
primera mujer que entra como editora en
la revista Time y empieza Pues a poner a
mujeres en color por primera vez y
empezamos a ver a figuras como stalin o
Hitler en las portadas esta tendencia se
mantiene En las siguientes tres décadas
en los años
50-60 y 70 cuando tres portavistas que
estuvieron tres décadas bajo las de
Danna tasker Pues hacen más de 900
portadas con ese símbolo del realismo
periodístico y con unas portadas con
mucha personalidad no se empiezan a
incorporar caricaturas vemos a Marilyn
Monroe a la Reina Isabel vemos a Kennedy
Luther King a los Beatles en el 67 y una
representación de la evolución humana en
el 77
en los años 80 vemos en portada a New
Walker Mosaico de la iconografía de cómo
es Dios Y cómo llega el computador a
nuestras vidas y luego pues esto ya es
un poco el reflejo de las siguientes
décadas hasta la actualidad Bueno sigo
insistiendo muy bello poder hacer un
repaso de la historia a través de una
publicación tan emblemática como esta en
este repaso de algunas de las portadas
más relevantes Marta de este siglo de
Time destaquemos algunas en concreto
porque las hay no que son bien
especiales de 5000 a 5 hemos hecho un
ejercicio de síntesis bárbaro destacamos
la la portada que es de 1966 que se
pregunta está muerto y es una icónica
portada de los años 60 la segunda es de
mayo de 2012 una portada También bien
polémica titulada eres lo
suficientemente madre la tercera que
hemos destacado es la caída de las
Torres Gemelas en septiembre de 2001 la
cuarta es de Aisha es de 2010 y es esta
mujer afgana sentenciada por los
talibanesa que le cortarán la nariz y
las orejas y la quinta portada que hemos
destacado es Donald Trump en 2016 con
esa niña refugiada inmigrante llorando
con el titular Bienvenidos a Estados
Unidos bien pues ahí la estamos viendo a
Donald Trump para que demos tiempo a
nuestros televidentes y vamos a hablar
de otro gran tema que además es noticia
en las salas de redacción y se espera
todos los años acerca de los grandes
iconos y la designación de la persona
del año que es un es un nombramiento que
a veces es polémico no así es Y esta es
una edición que nació en 19
cuando la revista Apenas tenía cuatro
años hemos querido destacar aquí en
pantalla al personaje del año de 2022
que no podía ser otro sino bolodimir
celenstein este reconocimiento según la
revista persé no tiene que tener una
connotación positiva Sin embargo a ojos
del público casi es como un premio a esa
persona que ha influido durante todo el
año no sin embargo pues han salido
personas en esta sección como Hitler
staling como Trump Putin incluso greta
que es la persona más joven que eligió
la revista Time para ser persona del año
y una parte que nos interesa
particularmente a usted y a mí y es otro
de los símbolos de la revista no su
proyección de las mujeres del año en
curso este jueves fue cuando Time
justamente sacó la lista de algunas de
estas mujeres que van a marcar el 2023
si es una lista de mujeres que según la
revista considera que han enfrentado
inmensos desafíos que las inspiraron a
cambiar el mundo ayer salió la lista de
esas doce mujeres que consideran la que
van a marcar de alguna manera este 2023
tenemos a mujeres de todo el mundo desde
jugadoras de fútbol actrices escritoras
boxeadoras activistas e incluso
políticas y referido ya a la región de
América Latina tenemos dos rostros
tenemos por una parte a Verónica Cruz
activista mexicana por la justicia
social y defensora del aborto y por otra
parte tenemos a aniel Franco a la nueva
ministra de igualdad racial de Brasil
hermana de Mariel Franco activista que
falleció en Río de Janeiro hace unos
años un gran icono gracias a Marta por
traernos este resumen que por supuesto
la invitación es a que los televidentes
vayan al sitio de la página Time y lo
revisen ellos mismos no cada uno con sus
intereses Muchas gracias a usted Marta
gracias Ángela